here are the latest calls between former
President Obama and President Trump
hello Iraq no extreme stop caring
my daughter about this clothing line
yeah I heard about that can I declare
war on Nordstrom no can I use a droid
strip
no what about Nordstrom Rack no can I
tweak that Nordstrom could get my ass
yes but that's beneath you
is it though a brac it's got a gauge
right yeah you don't need to say that I
know it's you Wow what's your problem
little pesky today I'm tired of you
calling me you're obviously not taking
any of my advice I don't see what the
point of these calls is the point is I
consider you a friend al Buraq I enjoy
talking to you is that true no I have no
human emotions
hello Buraq it's me
Donald you keep calling me what do you
want the love I never got from my
brother what I mean I want to destroy
rad there a new poll just came out you
and I have a 98% approval rating that's
not what I'm hearing where did that poll
come from a very respected Boley company
who did the poll a sample of anonymous
Americans you were standing near me at
the time and happy to be related to me
well that's not a legitimate poll and
and why was it only 98 percent the cats
voted against me I had him arrested for
treason hello Abe Iraq it's me I'm
working on my campaign slogan for 2020
that's premature
you're premature here's what I have so
far
say no to big news say yes to fake boobs
what do you think
you
[Applause]
you